il mio personale concetto di isola è
cambiato molto nel tempo
ricordo da ragazzo che mio padre che era
un pilota dell'aeronautica militare
mi disse che un'isola gli aveva salvato
la vita perché durante una complessa
manovra sull'oceano
aveva perso il senso dell'orizzonte si
trova a precipitare sull'oceano e
all'improvviso senza rendersene conto un
piccolo puntino nel centro nel nulla si
ingrandisce era un'isola è la visione di
quell'isola in qualche modo gli fece
capire che stava precipitando e lo
riportò a prendere il controllo
dell'aereo gli salvò la vita quando ero
piccolo per me esisteva un solo tipo di
isola l'isola del tesoro
immaginavo l'isola come un qualche cosa
di introvabile
per il quale serviva una mappa che ti
conducesse in questo tollo di terra
circondato dall oceano
senza quella mappa era praticamente
impossibile trovare l'isola un'isola che
quindi diventava uno spazio
completamente
incontaminato uno spazio che si evolveva
da solo dove le risorse stesse
dell'isola diventavano l'unica cosa
disponibile per l'evoluzione dell'isola
stessa
con il passare del tempo mi sono reso
conto che ci sono tantissimi tipi di
sono alcune isole non vengono percepite
per nulla come tali per esempio l'isola
di ortigia che in realtà è separata
dalla terraferma da pochissimi metri di
terra ma le isole nell'immaginario del
del bingo del simone di pochi anni erano
comunque un qualcosa che andava scoperto
e come si faceva a scoprire un isola e
come si faceva scoprire un'isola come la
sicilia
tremila anni fa quando la tecnologia
della navigazione consentiva a stento di
viaggiare per pochi giorni sul mare
sull'oceano bene in quel momento del
tempo l'uomo vedeva il mondo in una
forma diversa lo vedeva orientato in una
direzione diversa che la direzione del
sole e delle stelle e quindi si spostava
lungo le coste con tragitti che
coprivano soltanto un paio di giorni di
navigazione ed era inevitabile che
questi popoli arrivassero da più punti
in sicilia perché la sicilia si trovava
in una posizione è letteralmente
inevitabile era impossibile non
scoprirla anche senza una mappa del
tesoro e qui in effetti un tesoro lo
trovarono è un tesoro molto diverso da
quello che immaginiamo oggi ero un
tesoro fatto di di beni che per loro
erano fondamentali come come l'olio e
in quest isola incontaminata
decisero di stabilire la loro casa e
creare una civiltà fra le più belle del
mondo ma che cosa succede se un isola
rimane isolata se un'isola esaurisce le
proprie risorse naturali ecco che si
trasforma in qualcosa di diverso come
l'isola di pasqua cioè nasce si evolve
cresce e poi si estingue
completamente è un po quello che è
successo alla nostra terra che nel corso
degli ultimi due secoli ha perso una
grande parte delle risorse naturali però
ha perso forse una delle risorse più
preziose che che sono le risorse umane
le persone che con il loro lavoro e con
le loro idee hanno contribuito
all'evoluzione di questa terra persone
che nel tempo si sono spostate via
dall'isola perché non era più in grado
di sostenerle e quello che dire che era
inizialmente un'immigrazione di
manodopera di persone che provavano a
sfuggire alla loro condizione sociale
per avere una vita migliore nel tempo è
diventata una emigrazione una fuga di
cervelli anche io non sono sfuggiti a
questo fenomeno è così all'età di 19
anni dalla sicilia sono andato a finire
negli stati uniti perché avevo un
desiderio volevo volevo fare volevo
realizzare dei videogiochi
volevo creare un qualche cosa che sapevo
che qui in sicilia mi sembrava fosse
impossibile così risposto negli stati
uniti degli stati uniti
che nel nel mio immaginario erano la
california invece in realtà vado a
finire il massachusetts con temperatura
di meno 30 gradi quindi in un paesaggio
abbastanza diciamo in ospedale un po
come il paesaggio che hanno trovato i
padri pellegrini quando sono arrivati
negli stati uniti
di fatto sono arrivati nel nel periodo
autunnale per i primi mesi sono riusciti
a sopravvivere appena arrivato l'inverno
si sono salvati solo perché c'erano le
le popolazioni locali che letteralmente
le hanno che hanno nutriti no per questo
nasce il giorno del ringraziamento
perché senza di loro non sarebbero
sopravvissuti e
l'ambiente era inospitale però ho
trovato una cosa diversa l'accoglienza
l'accoglienza che è la condizione
necessaria per far avvenire la
contaminazione della contaminazione che
è la condizione necessaria per non
rimanere isolati
e così con un salto di 10.000 km o negli
stati uniti con il desiderio di
realizzare dei videogiochi in realtà
avete sentito prima ho avuto un percorso
un po più articolato e questo percorso è
partito con il desiderio di fare dei
videogiochi per un po come lo spostarsi
da un'isola all'altra è diventato un
qualche cosa di diverso
quando sono arrivato lì ho trovato
lavoro nella programmazione di un tipo
diverso di ciò che mi è stato chiesto di
programmare di sviluppare dei software
che animassero gli animatronics i raid
della disney per walt disney studios e
per altri parchi di intrattenimento che
nascevano in quelli che si evolvevano in
quegli anni negli stati uniti e così
invece di scrivere giochi veri e propri
iniziò a scrivere dei giochi che muovono
degli oggetti
da giochi
dei personaggi della disney la stessa
tipologia di software che muoveva e
animava questi dispositivi in realtà
poteva essere utilizzata per animare un
altra tipologia
di giochi giochi d'acqua per esempio
della fontana del villaggio a las vegas
in questo caso invece di muovere dei pub
et della disney quello che venivano
animate erano migliaia di pompe che
creavano getti d'acqua e migliaia di
luci che coordinate insieme con la
musica realizzavano uno spettacolo
d'arte è uno spettacolo d'arte che però
era generato da linee di codice scritte
in un programma e
e sempre in un percorso inaspettato di
salti gli spostamenti da una parte
all'altra da dalle tubazioni di acqua mi
trovo a scrivere dei programmi che
vengono utilizzati per
muovere non più acqua ma gas che si
sposta dalla siberia all'europa e viene
trasportato verso verso il nostro
continente e quindi questa volta invece
di migliaia di pompieri acqua ci sono
migliaia di valvole serbatoi che muovono
questi queste importanti combustibili e
da lì un ulteriore salto lo sviluppo di
applicazioni per il controllo delle
piattaforme petrolifere
un altro tipo di utilizzo della
tecnologia per il monitoraggio e
controllo delle operazioni offshore
immaginate centinaia di piattaforme
nell'atlantico nel pacifico in varie
parti del mondo che senza la presenza di
esseri umani operano ed estraggono
queste importanti risorse e dalle
piattaforme petrolifere
il passaggio è veramente breve
nell'andare a sviluppare dei software
che si occupano della movimentazione
della piattaforma di lancio dello
shuttle e di fatto con un processo che
porta da un gioco un gioco sempre più
complesso gli step vanno avanti e le
applicazioni diventano più serie quindi
la progettazione del building operation
command center del pentagono e poi
un'idea un'idea improvvisa una
realizzazione se volete che ha un po
cambiato la mia vita tutto quello che
facevo effettivamente era il risultato
di una contaminazione è una
contaminazione che derivava
dall'ambiente nel quale mi trovavo
infatti accanto a me avevo programmatori
che venivano dal pakistan dall'india
dalla siria dalla cina dalla germania da
tantissime parti del mondo dalla
repubblica ceca dall'australia
pochissimi americani
che non fossero di prima generazione e
tutte queste persone erano state accolte
in qualche modo e fra di noi si era
creato una contaminazione uno scambio di
idee e questo scambio di idee aveva reso
possibile con l'ambiente aveva reso
possibile la contaminazione di queste
idee la realizzazione di
di cose intangibili attraverso uno
strumento molto semplice per computer e
una connessione internet
e allora che cosa c'è di diverso
fra gli stati uniti e il resto del mondo
che cosa che cosa impedisce a quella
contaminazione di ritornare anche
indietro di andare nell'altra direzione
e quindi l'idea di iniziare a pensare
che cosa occorrerebbe per ricreare
quello stesso modello all'interno di un
altro territorio come la sicilia e
quindi nasce l'idea del ritorno di dare
il ritorno perché il mio concetto di
isola era cambiato non era più quella di
un'isola isolata geograficamente ma era
diventato il concetto di un'isola
isolata dal punto di vista dei dati oggi
questa conferenza va in streaming perché
è arrivata qui un cavo di rame che
consente a questo talk di essere
proiettato e scaricato da qualunque
parte d'italia del mondo con un click è
quello che innesca la contaminazione è
quella contaminazione è possibile perché
esistono dei cavi sottomarini come
l'american al gateway che
interconnettono tutto il mondo e guarda
caso la maggior parte di questi cavi che
coprono una lunghezza di quasi un
milione di chilometri quindi intorno
alla terra hanno in comune dei punti dei
punti di passaggio il 99 per cento delle
comunicazioni che vengono oggi nel mondo
intercontinentali e fatto attraverso
questi cavi sottomarini che di fatto per
una grande parte attraverso la sicilia
la sicilia perché nuovamente si trova al
centro di questo scambio di
telecomunicazioni e con sé si trovava in
un punto nevralgico tra l'est e l'ovest
sud del nord per cui molti di questi
casi di fatto non sono ricavi non solo
attraverso il mediterraneo ma anche la
sicilia quindi in realtà dei ponti in
sicilia ci sono sono dei ponti
intangibili difficili da vedere ma che
consentono di fare tante cose quindi
l'idea di ritornare in questo spazio
realizzare qualcosa in qualche senso in
qualche modo appare ancora più
realizzabile così eni insieme a degli
amici provenienti anche loro da altre
parti del mondo immaginiamo di
progettare uno spazio per la
contaminazione delle idee e di costruire
uno spazio che assomiglia e che renda
possibile questo scambio di idee fra
persone diverse lo realizziamo proprio
da zero e mettiamo insieme un qualcosa
che assomiglia a quello che avevamo
visto in altre parti del mondo e che
abbiamo vissuto in altre parti del mondo
e che era diventato parte del nostro
essere quindi quella contaminazione
ritorna indietro verso verso la sicilia
è così all'interno di questo spazio
realizziamo delle sale di monitoraggio e
telecontrollo da cui produrre i nostri
software per poi ri esportarli con un
click nella direzione opposta quindi
spedirli da qui agli stati uniti invece
di scaricare una app da qualche
blasonato
vendor di software negli stati uniti
facciamo il contrario
produciamo l'app qui e facciamo si che
altre persone in altre parti del mondo
scarichino queste app
realizziamo quindi uno spazio creativo
all'interno del quale queste idee
possono prendere piede e corpo e da qui
dalla sicilia riparte la contaminazione
nella direzione opposta quindi a questo
punto sono i software che con un bottone
utilizzando gli stessi punti digitali
utilizzando gli stessi spazi vengono
prodotti e vengono trasmessi altre parti
del mondo e quindi
l'idea che nasce da un nucleo di persone
piccolo qualsivoglia qui in sicilia
diventa la creazione di una
multinazionale
che apre centri di ricerca e sviluppo in
più parti del mondo quindi continua una
contaminazione nella direzione opposta
che poi diventa nuovamente
contaminazione da questi paesi nel
riportare indietro idee verso il nostro
quindi inizia uno scambio con il
sudafrica con la namibia con il brasile
con il marocco dove viene replicato lo
stesso modello idee con quale risultato
un risultato della creazione
innanzitutto di posti di lavoro con il
miglioramento del posizionamento
strategico
del nostro intero paese che diventa
protagonista e attore di una
trasformazione digitale creando delle
tecnologie che sono strategiche per il
posizionamento non solo l'italia nel
mediterraneo ma in tutto il mondo e da
qui oggi dalla sicilia
nascono e vengono progettati strumenti
avveniristici per esempio vedrete in
futuro presto approvato la comunità
europea il primo cuore totalmente
artificiale al mondo che già stato
trapiantato a 14 pazienti ma vedrete il
primo orecchio bionico vedrete i
software di controllo e monitoraggio
delle centrali elettriche oltre 100
gigawatt nel mondo e quell idea da di
contaminazione diventa un idea di
inclusione con oltre 400 persone che qui
in sicilia premono quello stesso bottone
che premevano prima negli stati uniti e
realizzano questi software
trasportandoli in tutto il mondo e
allora quali sono le cose che ho appreso
da questo viaggio da questa
contaminazione da questa insularità che
diventa esperienza il primo è che sono i
sogni che ci spingono ad andare oltre
andare lontano nel mio caso era un sogno
semplice volevo realizzare un videogioco
nel caso di altri magari un qualcosa di
diverso però quei sogni quelle idee sono
quelle che ci muovono e quando queste
idee sono profonde ci spingono a
superare i confini del nostro territorio
e che cosa succede quando si muoveva
fuori l'esplorazione diventa un modo per
contaminarsi e quella contaminazione
diventa valore l'altra cosa che lo ha
preso e che non c'è un viaggio se non ci
sono entrambe le parti del viaggio non
può esistere una partenza senza ritorno
non può esistere un ritorno senza una
partenza quindi bisogna intraprendere
quel quel viaggio ma la più importante
fonte di energia che pro pelle oggi
tutte le nostre le nostre idee alla fine
sono le persone sono quelle che
letteralmente muovono il mondo
trasformano il territorio e rendono
possibile che una solfara diventi un
centro di scambio culturale l e di idee
e poi la lezione più importante di tutti
che senza ponti nel mio caso ponti
digitali
rimarremo tutti i naufraghi su
quest'isola grazie
[Applauso]